[Musique]
se présentait à la Chambre des communes
comme députés j'ai promis à ma famille
que je quitterai la vie politique après
avoir déposé en chambre le rapport final
sur l'aide médicale à mourir ce que j'ai
pu faire le 15 février il assure que sa
récente dissidence avec le parti pour
défendre les anglophones n'a pas pesé
dans la balance je me suis prononcé et
oui bien sûr j'étais attaqué mais défend
on fait des choses dans la vie par
principe la retraite sera la quatrième
vie de marguerneau d'abord officier de
la marine canadienne il est ensuite
devenu le premier Canadien à aller dans
l'espace
[Musique]
son premier voyage en tant
qu'astronautre monte à 1984 est-ce que
vous allez recommencer si j'ai encore
une deuxième chance certainement oui il
fera un deuxième vol en 1996 et même un
troisième en 2000 avant de prendre la
tête de l'Agence spatiale canadienne ses
premiers pas en politique c'est une
campagne perdue en 2006 dans westmond
Ville-Marie il sera finalement élu en
2008 et ne quittera pas son siège de
député jusqu'à son départ
[Musique]
dans le gouvernement des voix
ensoleillées de 2015 il obtient une
place au cabinet Trudeau monsieur Marc
Garnaud ministre des Transports
et en 2021 il prend la tête de la
diplomatie canadienne mais seulement
pour quelques mois car après les
élections d'octobre mais elle est jolie
ministre des Affaires étrangères Marc
Garnaud n'a pas caché sa déception de ne
plus être autour de la table du Conseil
des ministres il a ensuite refusé le
poste d'ambassadeurs à Paris non sa
circonscription les électeurs sont
partagés
à l'aise avec sa position quant à ses
collègues c'est l'unanimité
propre convictions je vous remercie pour
son courage de détermination et aussi sa
grande humilité on a beaucoup à prendre
de vie il a tout mon admiration et je le
remercie énormément pour pour tout ce
qu'il a fait
à 74 ans Marc Garnaud n'a pas d'autre
projet que de profiter de ces retraites
et de ses proches ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada Montréal